costume iMac to last week I wonder if
you remember and I've given you like
some visual prompts here right I wonder
if you remember seeing this probability
density function it was just an example
in fact we talked about it even before
we had this you know firm idea in
continuous random variables I introduced
it as an example of a discrete
probability distribution that exhibits
characteristics of a continuous
distribution so it's like if you've got
a continuous model that fits that then
use that because it's really good at
predicting things right now we're gonna
use this as our way to sort of explore
this idea which we've talked about in
like broad brushstrokes but not in
detail okay so let's think about a quick
example here okay if I asked you off of
this probability just don't sit a
function right what's the probability
for example of you know the number of
heads face up being I don't know between
10 and 12 right the probability of it
being between 2010 and 12 okay we've
established okay well you can integrate
to find the area under this function and
that'll give you the probability yadus
ringabel
okay so we would form an integral okay
what would its boundaries be tended to a
hub right you're like those two numbers
they're homeruns I've got 10 and 12 I
actually gave you what this particular
function was it was like e to the power
of some you know weird crazy stuff but
let's for now just say whatever that
function happens to be and then you
integrate with respect to X and then the
definite integral you get an answer out
that number will be your probability
okay one thing we didn't really address
though is that often we don't state we
don't ask for probabilities where you've
got to need boundaries I could just as
easily ask for a probability like this
what's the probability that the number
of heads face up is greater than or
equal to 14 this would be a pretty
normal thing to ask the only problem is
with a question like this you can't
neatly convert it over to here right
like I'm I think to myself I need to
form an integral right I think okay well
X is greater than 14 so I started 14
let's put 14 like around there okay
and then I start working on an area to
the right of that because it's greater
than yeah so I start to get and I'd love
you put this on your diagram as well I
start to get an area that looks like
this
but I sort of run into this little snag
in that my integral has a lower bound
but it has no upper bound right at least
not one that's just handed to you
straight out so the whole point here is
there is a domain restriction on this
probability density function it's I
haven't said it but it's kind of implied
in the situation that allows us to fill
in the rest of what's going on I can't
at least with the tools that we've got
there
I can't just integrate to forever these
have some endpoint think back what what
is the situation modeling how many coins
do I have right we said 20 coins right I
was just why my x-axis stops at 20 so in
fact here at 20 there's an implied
endpoint to my integral does that make
sense even though there's it's not here
you kind of have to read into it say ah
well I'm not going to go forever
I'm gonna go from 14 to 20 and then I'm
gonna integrate like I did before and
clearly you can imagine here that you
know if this is what it means going to
the right you might have the same thing
going to the left do you agree if pick
out a point like say watch this just
lets leave it at 14 right if I wanted
the probability of X is less than or
equal to 14 yeah let me get a different
color up so I'm now going to say I'm
going to start integrating from
somewhere over here and then go to 14
right so you're gonna end up with this
area on this side again there is a start
point implied by the situation even
though it's not told to you right what's
the domain restriction that's relevant
here zero lie is yes I can't have
negative numbers of coins that are our
heads face up right so therefore over
here and this is quite common right you
will often go from zero to some sensible
value and that 0 is going to be the
bottom of my integral I should say the
UM the lower boundary so from nought to
14 of that function okay so we can
generalize this right you're going to
have functions which are defined
in some kind of area right so if we
generalize this rather than you know
this specific situation if you've got a
probability density function that lives
between some values a and B if you ask
for the probability of something in the
middle greater than that or something in
the middle less than that right let's
just pick out a spot like say over here
right so if you have some given value
any value like I'm just going to call it
value okay can you form for me the
integrals that correspond to the
probability of this is an x-axis over
here of the x value being less than that
value what would be the integral that I
formed okay yep so I'm just here's my
here's my my integrand in here whatever
that function happens to be but the
boundaries of the main thing I'm
interested in here right where am I
going to start am I going to start have
a think this is less than the value
right ah good I'm going to start at a
maybe again this is why I put the colors
here right yeah you're at my endpoint
already you're you're a step ahead of me
so maybe if you want to color this into
your region here right start point end
point so I'm gonna go from a up to my
value does that make sense now this is
interesting right like we're kind of
drowning a little bit in alphabet soup
here because you've got so many
different pronumeral flying around
especially when you generalize to some
like who knows what function this is so
I'm not going to call this X because
it'll actually be a number and I'm using
X in all kinds of other places so we use
X a lot right so I'm gonna try and avoid
overusing it in exactly the same way
what if I looked at the other side what
if I wanted the probability of being
above that value yeah fantastic I'm
starting from the value and I'm going to
the right but I don't just go forever I
stop at a point right so it's from the
value up to B now it's important that
you kind of like to think about this
explicitly because these domain
restrictions like I said then I just get
handed to you like you might not get
notation that says oh you know this guy
is defined as less than
then babe they won't always explicitly
say that to you you might have to read
that out of the situation that you get
sort of described to you right